there's no place I'd rather be in this
world Oh God that song is hi Bruno
where's your balls that song gets me
right here hey what's going on YouTube
now you guys sent me a very very funny
article I love it when you send me funny
[ __ ] and this right here is a doozy a
self-styled minutes Oh Ryan Williams
decide to go on a tweet rant about how
women should control their bladders and
buy bladders I mean their period that so
before I continue let's just go through
a few of the tweets that he wrote Tampa
should not be free why does everyone
keep saying they should be if you can't
control your bladder then that's not
taxpayers problems this is the saddest
[ __ ] tweet I've ever heard in my life
you know there's a major flaw in what
you just tweeted there do you not know
the difference between the female
reproductive system and the [ __ ]
bladder you are the dumbest [ __ ]
I have never met in my life the bladder
and the uterus are not the same do you
know what a uterus is your parents have
[ __ ] failed you hook it you're a cute
little [ __ ] aren't you
you're [ __ ] 19 years old you dumb
[ __ ] women can't hold their periods
because it's not connected or is it from
their bladder so every time your
girlfriend had to use a tampon or a pad
you're saying to yourself there she goes
again spilling her eggs all over the
place it's really hard to understand at
the age of 19 and you almost being 20
that you don't know what a [ __ ]
uterus is and by the way what the hell
is a menaced is that the opposite of a
feminist because we as men neither need
to come together to make sure that the
women's are not oppressing us I get it I
get I don't get it and can't we talk
about this last tweet that he tweeted
out and just for the record I don't
think condoms should be free either
close your legs and hold your bladder
end of discussion
oh my god does David so have to choke a
bear close your legs what the [ __ ] is
going on in this world the funny thing
is he actually stated that his
girlfriend
ever believes [ __ ] if your girl
isn't bleeding the [ __ ] is pregnant or
you're never [ __ ] in your life let me
roast your dumb ass for a second you
stupid [ __ ] the fact that you even got a
woman to touch you is a miracle in and
of itself
number one fix your [ __ ] up hair your
hair looks like it got into an argument
with a pair of scissors and lost what
the [ __ ] did you do go into a barber and
ask him can I just get a fade on the
side and then get me something that'll
never get me [ __ ] ever [ __ ] who cut
your hair Michael J Fox oh that's wrong
I can't looking like you did head spins
on razor blades [ __ ] and don't even get
me started on the [ __ ] teeth
[ __ ] your teeth look like a braces
nightmare [ __ ] your teeth look like an
open bag of Cheetos looking like you
want a steady diet of rocks and dynamite
[ __ ] can you sit there put on
your Twitter and say that you're a
menace and a self-proclaimed activist as
somebody of intellectual thought when
you don't know the difference between a
bladder and a [ __ ] uterus women
cannot hold their period it comes out
that's why they have tampons that's why
they have ads whatever woman out there
allows your dick to be inside them good
you need to reevaluate and let's just go
beyond the ugly [ __ ] I don't understand
to this day why guys have a problem with
a period the menstrual cycle listen to
me [ __ ] if you haven't figured
it out by now every woman that you're
with or going to be with if you are a
heterosexual male is going to go through
their [ __ ] period apparently out
there there's this concept that men are
disgusted by it you when a woman talks
about her period you guys freaked the
[ __ ] out [ __ ] this ain't Hogwarts and
we're not saying Baltimore it's a
[ __ ] period you know what I do for my
girlfriend this is straight up this is
not me trying to like fluff myself up
and [ __ ] everywhere I go I carry a
backpack and inside my backpack is some
pads tell me I ain't about it look at
the [ __ ] work [ __ ] right here
again Oh take that [ __ ] away
you know why because I do understand
that this is a bodily function that she
goes through so for me that is a man
that's supposed to be her partner
that's supposed to be complementary to
her life I want to make her life easy in
case we go somewhere and that [ __ ]
strikes and I'm like listen we don't
need to go to a CBS or a store and go
ahead
up somewhere and you don't need to be
ashamed for it I got you I'm your man
and I got your [ __ ] back and if you
bleed not your [ __ ] that's what your
boys for there's gonna be a few you guys
out there they hear they said you're
gonna be like oh my god look at you
you're just trying to be kept in stable
home food no [ __ ] I've been thinking
about this [ __ ] before it became a huge
hype on social media I couldn't even
wrap my head around what period shaming
was I never grew up with that [ __ ]
acting like a [ __ ] woman's menstrual
cycle is the atomic bomb what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you your life is terrible
menace what the [ __ ] is wrong how you
gonna be ugly and stupid you ain't got a
single advantage in life BAM [ __ ]
I'll be rolling in the [ __ ] everyone
think that they should be if you can't
control your bra blah but the [ __ ] a
bra bra